hi everyone my name is urban fazel
and today i'm going to present you a
recent paper
data driven and non-linear air elastic
models of morphing wings for
control this is joint work with nikola
fonsi and steve brunton and we published
a work in
proceedings of the royal society
a so the goal of this work was to
develop aeroelastic models of
morphing wings and the approach that we
chose is
based on the dynamic
mode decomposition with control and the
idea is to
define models for morphing wings
that are also suitable for control
so the idea of morphing wings
is that we want to
improve the performance of a flight
system by enabling adaptability
over large operating
conditions and the best example for this
can be found in nature
where for example here a falcon
perfectly adapts its wings throughout
this hunting maneuver so it starts
with a high aspect ratio and
gliding and then enters a teardrop
dive to maximize its flight speed
and finally it morphs its wing to this
m-type configuration to generate strong
wing and tail vortices
to improve the maneuverability for a
prey capture
so the bird perfectly adapts its wing
shape throughout
this uh hunting dive by morphing
its wings and our goal is now to also
achieve similar adaptability with our
engineered flight systems
and of course we are not exactly there
yet but there is a lot of research
ongoing in the morphing wings community
so what you can see uh for example in
these two videos is a
recent work from siemens lab at eth
zurich
in the top video you can see a 3d
printed composite
morphing wing and on the lower video
you can see a distributed compliance
lattice
structure morphing wing and the goal of
both of these wings
is first to replace
conventional ailerons by using morphing
for
roll control and then in the case of the
upper wing
we basically placed compliant rips
over the full wingspan
to be able to change the span wise
lift distribution at different flight
conditions
and operating modes and one main
challenge of developing morphing wings
is that they are inherently
flexible so there is a tight coupling
between the structural
and the aerodynamic response and that's
pretty difficult to model and especially
also
to control so the goal is
here to find accurate and efficient
models for morphing wings that are then
also suitable
for control
modeling of morphing wings or flexible
wings in general is not something new
so there's a lot of research or there
was a lot of research over the last
decades and there's still a lot of
research ongoing
so for example what you can see in this
animation
here is a really cool work done by the
group of
professor palacios they
analyze mainly a very flexible wings
and wind turbine blades and what you can
see here
in this animation is a t-tail high
altitude long endurance
vehicle that is encountering a ghost and
they simulate
this very flexible aircraft using their
simulation toolbox
sharpie where they model the wing
structure
as exact beam
elements and couple the structural model
with an unsteady vortex lotis method
and in the case of modeling morphing
wings we use a very similar approach
the big difference in terms of modeling
the structure is that
additionally to the flexibility like the
bending and the torsional flexibility of
the wing
we also want to model the cambering of
the wing so how the
the airfoil actually changes and
therefore instead of using
a beam element beam
or an exact beam element method we use a
more detailed
shell element based finite element model
so what you can see here in this figure
is an exploded view of our high aspect
ratio
morphing wing with the top wing surface
the bottom wing surface and the internal
structure so the internal structure
consisting of the two
spars and the ribs
and in this case we have rigid ribs
at the inner part of the wings from here
to here and on the outer part we have
the morphing ribs so that the compliance
structure that
replace the ailerons
then similar to the unsteady vortex
lattice method
we use a 3d unsteady panel method so we
also reduce the problem to
the surface of the wing and
the wake and ultimately what we solve
for both
methods is a set of
non-linear differential algebraic
equations
and this is very important to consider
if we then later want to
uh develop a reduced order model
but ultimately what is the issue with
this is that
those methods are comparably efficient
but they're still way too slow to be
used for control
so we want to develop a data-driven
reduced order
model of our morphing wing that would
enable us to the model to be used for
control
and specifically we use the method
dynamic mode decomposition with control
dmdc
and we introduce two extensions
extensions to this model the first one
is we introduce a formulation to
a handle the algebraic equation so this
is fundamental as i said before
that's basically the equations that
we solve so we need this extension that
dmdc can also handle these algebraic
equations
and then second we are interested in
developing a reduced order model that is
valid over a large
operating regime and therefore we
introduce an interpolation scheme that
can
connect several admdc models so that we
then finally end up having
a parametric admdc model that is valid
over
a larger flight speed range or operating
range
and uh to start with i want to introduce
what dynamic mode composition actually
does so first
in dmdc we need to collect data
so what you see here for is for example
the flow around the cylinder
we run a numerical simulation and a
different time step
as we take snapshots of our state of
interest in this case of our
flow field and in the case of um
flexible wings of or of our morphing
wing
we are mainly interested in the wing
deformations
and the pressure distribution
on the surface of our wing so we're not
exactly
interested in what's going on in the
flow around the wing but we really want
to know what's happening
on the wing and therefore we define
the state of interest for the morphing
wing
as the wing deformations
and the singularity strength on the wing
surface
and in case of the wing deformations we
don't look at the actual wing
deformations but we look at or
modal modal coordinates already so at
the
structural vibration and morphing
modes as our coordinate system for
the deformations okay and
in terms of the inputs of our model
we basically have two sets of inputs
first uh the wing flight states so
the angle of attack and the rotation
rates
these are like the first four inputs
and then second the morphing
inputs so how we actually deform uh
our wings so when you think about the
videos from the previous
slide and in reality we place for
example servo actuators or some type of
actuators to really
camber so deform our our wing
and those are inputs to our model
and then we run
a simulation so we impulsively
excite our inputs and we take snapshots
at the
different time step and then in a second
step
we organize our data so we have our
snapshots
and we place them or we kind of like
organize them in
three matrices uh x consists
of uh the snapshot at time step one time
step two
etc x prime are the snapshots of our
state
shifted in time so the first column is
the snapshot at the snapshots at time
step 2
then 3 etc and third we have
our input matrix
epsilon that consists of the inputs
at time step one two etc
and then what dm dc does is
it finds or it tries to find a best fit
linear model that advances our state x
into x prime considering the inputs
epsilon and ultimately
so ultimately we want to find the two
linear operators a
and b and how this is done is by
first reformulating this into
x prime so x prime
equals c which is our unknown operators
times sigma which are our known
snapshots
and then by using an svd
we can take the pseudo inverse of sigma
and solve
here for c
and that's basically that's how we can
get our best fit uh
linear model using uh this data
and then in the case of our algebraic
system what we need to do is we need to
consider those algebraic terms
so what we do is that we not just find
the best fit linear model
advancing x into x prime considering the
inputs but additionally we also
consider our algebraic terms so our
time shifted inputs so basically
epsilon primes is similar to x prime is
that we shift our inputs by one time
step so our first column will be
the inputs at time step 2 then 3 etc
but then apart from that we can apply
exactly the same method like
in a dmd c so we reformulate this
formula here so x prime equals
c times uh sigma there it is
we take the pseudo inverse to solve
for c and we have our best fit
linear model okay and then having this
model we can
look at the dynamics so we can
reshape basically our dynamic modes so
we can take the
eigenvalues or approximate approximately
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of our
system
and then reshape the eigenvectors into
let's call it like
eigen wing shapes and eigensingularity
strength
with the corresponding time dynamics
we can then that's basically what we
want to have
uh predict future states so we can
advance
our state x into uh x at time step and
into
the state x at time time step n plus one
considering our inputs and our algebraic
terms
and then the last thing very important
is that those states
might be comparably high dimensional so
this model might still be very slow and
not be applicable for control
so actually what we do is that we never
really
need to calculate those large matrices
a b and f or
combined the matrix c but we directly
project it onto the dominant modes svd
modes
of our output space x prime
and this gives us then a super compact
uh
reduced order uh model of our dynamics
so basically we can
directly without ever calculating see
get our
dynamic matrices or the operators a b
and f tilde and what is really nice
about this method is that we can still
go
between those reduced states to
the full physical states by using our
dominant svd modes of the output spacex
prime okay so this is how we
define and build our dmdc or admdc
model then in our paper we show or we
apply
this to three examples first the generic
and differential algebraic system of
equations
where we show that it's not only
important to use
this algebraic extension to get accurate
results but if we don't use this
extension we get
unstable system dynamics
second we apply admdc to
aerodynamics only problem so to a naka
double o 12
rigid wing and then finally we apply the
method
to our morphing wing so as i mentioned
before the state of interest
is the wing deformations and the
singularity strength
and the inputs to our model are the
flight state so
angle of attack three rotation rates and
um the morphing actuation
and then in the first step we train our
model so that's basically
the two steps that i mentioned before so
collecting data
and organizing data so we
um impulsively excite
our inputs in a random order and take
snapshots
of our state then we can build our admdc
model
and we then have
two test cases so first we test
our model by using
sinusoidal inputs with different reduced
frequencies in the direction of the
different inputs
and second we use
a different like a random set of
impulsive
inputs in the direction yeah in the
direction of our inputs
yeah and with those testing phases what
we basically want to do is we want to
compare
our full and reduced order model so
what you see here in this plot is first
the
lift coefficient and the drag
coefficient and the roll coefficient
the yellow continuous line is the
reduced order model
and the blue dash line is the full model
and
what we get is like really excellent
agreement between
the full and the reduced order model and
on top of that we get
a speed up of three orders of magnitude
so our reduced order model is super
accurate
and also super fast okay
so um so far i showed you results for a
single
reduced order model so a model that is
valid at a specific
operating condition but as i mentioned
before we're actually interested in
developing a reduced order model that is
valid over a larger
range of operating conditions so what we
then
basically do is that because
we have those super fast
compact models our idea is to simply
run several local reduced order models
in parallel
project the local reduced state
up to our full physical state and then
interpolate the physical state
so what we do is we have our inputs
then in this schematic we have three
local models
so one two three and then
each for each local model
we advance our reduced state q
a time step n to q a time step n
plus one by considering the inputs and
the algebraic terms
and then project the reduced state up
to our full physical state and then
interpolate
the full physical state at our operating
condition of interest so in this case at
the flight speed
of interest and that's basically that's
how we
interpolate several local reduced order
models
we then also test this approach
using the similar set of inputs so first
different sinusoidal inputs
with different reduced frequencies and
then the impulsive inputs in a second
testing phase but compared
to the plot that i showed before
additionally here
we sweep over a velocity range so
basically we accelerate our wing
from 35 to 80 meters per second
and again we get excellent agreement
between the reduced and the full
model and even introducing this
interpolation
we still get a speed up of three orders
of magnitude
so then last to show
the performance of our modeling approach
we incorporate the admdc model into a
model predictive control framework and
we run
several control examples so for example
we try to mitigate
gusts or we try to follow a specific
lift coefficient and trajectory
and then ultimately we want to use our
admdc model
to control the loads on an airborne wind
energy drone
and what an airborne wind energy drone
is it's basically a
tethered drone that is used to harvest
wind energy and the idea of using
this admdc a model predictive control is
to be able to fly closer to the maximum
wing loading and closer to the maximum
tether loading so that we can basically
improve uh the performance of this uh
airborne
uh wind energy system and in our paper
we show that we can indeed uh reduce uh
gust peaks of such an airborne uh wind
energy
drone okay
so to summarize we developed a data
driven
reduced order model of a morphing wing
we showed its
performance in terms of accuracy and
speed up
and we also applied or used the admdc
model for model predictive control
and you can find the link to the paper
in the description of the video below
you can also find a link to nikola skit
top
for the code and additionally
i added some links to the work of
professor palacios
and to the work that we recently
recently published at sema's lab
in terms of morphing wings thanks for
watching